hey everybody it's Jake here coming at
you with another Jake's Take which we
haven't done in a while since thymesia
came out but today we are going to talk
about scorn this game has an amazing
amount of creepy atmosphere and is
absolutely disgusting to play watch
everything about it is gross it's moist
it's disgusting I likely will never play
this game again for more reasons than it
just being gross let me get the good
things out of the way because I
definitely have more bad things to talk
about with this game for sure because
I'll just get this out of the way really
quickly I did not enjoy playing this
game at all I think I had a little bit
of fun playing the first 45 minutes
maybe I thought the first level in
Puzzles were actually kind of
interesting but after that the game
really fell flat for me when it started
introducing its other mechanics
especially the combat system and I fully
understood the game that I was playing
was just a really cool looking puzzle
game like I said it has an amazingly
creepy atmosphere it hits every type of
artistic design that it was going for
everything in the game has an amazing
level of detail when it comes to the
graphics of this game and the atmosphere
that they were going for and the game
art style and design they absolutely
killed it with this game it is perfect
other than that I feel the game
completely Falls flat and everything
else that it was trying to do it fully
committed to the design style that it
was going for and it succeeded in that
but everything else about the game is so
unenjoyable and just not fun which is
what I am looking for when I am playing
a video game the game has no dialogue so
there's nothing really to confirm what's
going on in the game and nobody is
talking there's nothing that you can
read You're simply just walking around
this world and trying to understand
what's going on and it never fully
telling you anything about everything
the game has some choices that you can
pick from but I had to go ahead and
watch the ending because I really didn't
enjoy myself so much that I didn't even
finish the game which is very very rare
for me to do I got completely stuck on a
puzzle that gave me brain rot and I just
I didn't want to play the game anymore I
am usually very good at grinding through
a game even if I don't like it to
finally finish the game to see what
happens and with this game I literally
stopped playing it and had to look up
the endings there are a few endings
there are some lore aspects to the game
but nothing that is really all that
interesting to be honest with you and no
questions that you have will ever be
answered there is nothing that we can go
off in this game besides just
environmental storytelling which we are
used to with all the souls games and
Elden ring and stuff like that but other
than that there's nothing to read
there's no item descriptions that we can
go over the game doesn't tell you
anything and you just have to infer
everything which isn't really up my
alley to be honest the game is an
extremely interesting world but there's
nothing really to connect any of the
lore aspects together so if you're going
into this for the story I wouldn't
recommend it at all the entire game
itself in the gameplay of it is all
complicated puzzles the puzzles are
somewhat fun at least at the beginning
but then the later puzzles that I'm
showing on screen here I don't like them
I did not enjoy doing these puzzles in
this gross world and it definitely
doesn't help that everything between the
puzzles is just a walking simulator to
go to the puzzles you get these
interesting weapons that are just awful
I cannot preface this enough that the
combat system in this game is simply
unenjoyable it feels tacked on and just
kind of like they threw it in there at
the end to just make it not a complete
walking puzzle Simulator the enemies you
fight against move too quickly and use
their attacks too quickly for you to
actually Dodge any attacks that they
send at you the weapons that you do get
which I got a shotgun and this kind of
blow dart thing that kind of stretches
out and then comes back into your weapon
they barely do anything these guys it
takes like four or five hits to actually
kill an enemy and then all you're doing
is walking around the enemy hoping that
whatever attack they're doing doesn't
hit you the combat system in this game
is a complete joke I think it would have
done better if they just didn't have any
combat at all and it really doesn't help
that when you're doing that frustrating
combat you are just walking to the next
complicated puzzle I think frustrating
combat walking to a complicated puzzle
walking to another complicated puzzle
just to do more frustrating combat into
another complicated puzzle equals my
brain hurting too much for me to even
deal with what's going on and I'm
actually glad I didn't keep playing the
game because the endings were not worth
it at all I obviously don't want to
spoil anything for you guys in case you
do want to play the game but the endings
did not justify everything that I did
through the game it didn't explain
anything about it it didn't make me want
to grind through to get the other
endings because there is some choices
that you can do in the game where you
use either a scoop or a saw on some guy
the beginning that we ended up calling
Kevin in my stream because we have no
idea what's going on you don't even know
your own main character's name I I
understand that that's what the game was
going for it's going for this mysterious
dark atmospheric creepy disgusting gross
bloody game but it just fell flat for me
in almost every way if you do end up
dying to the enemies in the game the
checkpoint and save system is so bad
that it will throw you back minutes
beforehand where you will have to go
through the same scripted animations so
that you can finally get back to where
you previously died from I cannot tell
you how annoying that is I haven't
played a game that had this bad of a
checkpoint system in a long time and it
really just added to all the extra
frustration that I had the puzzles can
be so complicated that I spent almost 45
minutes on this puzzle that you're
seeing right now that I decided to just
reload the game so that I could get a
fresh start on the puzzle entire rarely
and when I did this I realized that the
game did not auto save for the last hour
and 45 minutes and this is where I
completely quit the game I was not gonna
go through an hour extra of a walking
simulator to just do another complicated
puzzle that I was just trying to restart
anyway and what sucks about this is I
was really looking forward to this game
I love this type of design it kind of
reminds me of bloodborne in a lot of
ways where they were going for complete
atmosphere but they fell flat in every
single other category that I cannot
recommend this game to any of you if you
like frustrating puzzles and walking
around a cool area then you should play
this game I think you will enjoy it I
don't think it's a bad game but it's not
a game that I ever want to touch again
at least for me but like I said I do not
recommend it thank you for watching the
video and I will see you all in the next
Jake's Take have a good one
foreign